my name is ali shithu
my school is government science kansas
kankara i'm come here at study at
particular science county school
i'm in final year class i entered my
work at nuku
in government science county ratio
of the length of side in a right angle
triangle
with respect to one angle
i want to study microbiology because
in nigeria microbiology are not many
that is why i i want to study
microbiology
opposite to the anger cheetah you call
it
opposite and the other side will be
and said that the learning we are doing
is not good
they told us that in devotion the
learning we are doing is not good
yes learning is good because every
muhammad
she's learning students most of them
we are very hungry and the trees
the trees leaves of trees
even me i was crying because i didn't
think
the i have the
the situation where my mother is yeah
i have two brothers and the
our parents said that we should go back
to kangaroo
anything can happen even where you are
he said that we should go back to
kankara
and we are the government the government
said that
every student he should go to near this
country school
near to him he go online
well let's speak to peter hawkins about
this he's a unicef representative in
nigeria and joins us now from abuja
peter very good to have you with us on
al jazeera
why are school children in nigeria in
particular being targeted
what's fueling this crisis
there are a number of things that are
fueling the crisis and this crisis
remember has been going on for a number
of years
but intensified since uh december and
one of the key issues here
is to try and generate intelligence to
understand
what is fueling this crisis so you have
the insurgency
primarily in the north east which is
fundamentally ideological
you have conflict in different parts of
the country mainly around the the
settlers and
and the the nomads uh but you also have
the criminality
uh element which uh is is looking at
extortion
they are a soft target these schools uh
many of them are in rural areas a lot of
them have very little protection around
them
and actually taking 300 girls while
logistically very difficult
in terms of securities it is quite easy
they are
soft targets with a lot to gain from it
what impact is this having are these
kidnappings and attacks having on on
nigeria's education system
profound and and let's not forget on the
the children themselves
it's the most uh intense i mean i lord
your correspondent for finding
a child who has seen this as a a
positive thing to
come back and and the resilience of
those children are fantastic but we
cannot underestimate
the profound impact on these children
and psychosocial care for them
is our first priority but on parents
themselves
who are saying in different parts of the
country
look look what's happening over there is
it going to happen to
my school where my children are at and
not only are schools being closed but
parents are withdrawing their children
from uh at a school of this kind
and that has having a profound impact on
the morale of education
on the learning experience and the
continuous learning experience that
children
require and have a right to let's not
forget and it builds on the uncertainty
that
the covert 19 pandemic has brought to
the
that learning experience so what's being
done then peter to secure
these schools and make these school
children safe i know that a safe school
initiative was launched after the
chibok girls kidnapping but that doesn't
cover the northwest of nigeria where
these recent kidnappings have happened
how successful has that initiative been
and what's being done by the government
to make schools more safe
as you rightly point out there was
initiative in the north northeast after
the chibok girls that
that continues that has morphed into
different ways of looking at
security around education not only
around the schools themselves but
education within the schools around
conflict around landmines and
also bringing children into safer areas
where they can formally or informally
continue their education
and we've seen the success of that in in
my degree where
there are thousands of children going to
school in actual fact so many that their
traffic jams during the day compared to
in 2015 for example where there were
no schools and no children going to
school but in in the northwest we
brought together the minister of finance
brought together the
security sector the minister of
education
uh the governors uh and the
international community to
agree on a compact on understanding what
is the
underlying problem so the intelligence
and what it is
to try and get state to state
security plans to see where are the
problems
and what are those problems in trying to
secure
uh schools and secure education but i
think the most important
part of all of this is this relationship
between the schools
and their community it's trying to
enhance that
uh show the community the value of
learning
show give the community some sort of
incentive
that they would protect the uh the
schools themselves
we saw many in many of these attacks
it's the local people who
have been helping the the attacks take
place
okay thank you so much for talking to us
about this peter hawking [ __ ]
unicef representative in nigeria thank
you for your time
thank you thank you